is Martin Luther King Jr Day the nation  pauses to honor the late civil rights  leader for 41 years that honoring has  included a parade right through downtown  Las Vegas today's events started at 10  o'clock along 4th Street local groups  filled the streets to show their support  for Dr King and what he stood for we  spoke with a Morehouse graduate who says  he attended school with Dr King's  children  does the show  the show done and achieved to this point  but also brings forth and brings to life  what what remains to be done and what  remains to be worked on in terms of  racial justice social justice protection  of opposing rights the protection of  democracy itself  and we'll have full coverage of the  parade and Dr King's Legacy Nationwide  and here in the US and here in Las Vegas  in later shows this is 8 news now we're  back after this